vamos a agarrar un poco más de práctica
en esto de sumar dos polinomios pero
ahora cuando tienen más de una variable
aquí tenemos x g y lo que queremos hacer
es sumar estas dos expresiones sumar 4x
cuadrada y menos 3x cuadrada menos 2 con
8 x y menos 3x cuadrada más 2 x cuadrada
y más 4 y lo primerito que a mí me viene
así a la vista es que este paréntesis de
acá estos paréntesis no nos sirven de
nada porque simplemente estamos haciendo
una suma entonces déjame quitar los
paréntesis y nos quedaría 4x cuadrada 4x
cuadrada y menos 3 x cuadrada menos 2
y ponemos el segundo término el segundo
polinomio 8x y menos 3x cuadrada más 2x
cuadrada y es cuadrada y más 4 muy bien
y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
agrupar términos similares déjame
empezar con este con el 4x cuadrada y
entonces una pregunta buena es ver si
esto lo podemos sumar con otro término
hay algún término similar hay algún otro
término con x cuadrada y pues si este
otro término el 2x cuadrada ya también
es de la forma x cuadrada y por tanto
estos dos términos los podemos sumar si
tenemos 4x cuadrada jeff y le sumamos 2x
cuadrada y entonces nos quedaría 6x
cuadrada y muy bien pasemos ahora a los
términos del estilo x cuadrada voy a
poner los de color naranja entonces aquí
tenemos un menos 3 x cuadrado este
término se lo podemos sumar a alguien
más hay otro que tenga x cuadrada pues
si aquí hay otro menos 3x cuadrada vamos
a ver cuánto nos da si tenemos menos 3x
cuadrada y le restamos otros 3x
cuadradas entonces entonces nos quedan
menos menos 6 x cuadrada muy bien
entonces eso termina con los x cuadradas
ya no hay más x cuadrada vamos con este
menos 12 vamos a ver qué pasa menos 12
hay algún otro término similar a éste
que nada más tenga y pues no este es x y
este es un término constante entonces el
único término con que es menos 2 y
entonces lo ponemos aquí menos 2
pasemos ahora a este 8x con color
amarillo amarillo un poco más fuerte
entonces tenemos este 8x que al parecer
tampoco lo podemos sumar a nada porque
nada más nos queda este 4 entonces le
pongo más 8x y finalmente déjame tomar
este color verde para indicar el término
constante que voy a copiar aquí más 4
muy bien entonces ya agrupamos todos
nuestros términos similares y
simplificamos tanto como fue posible y
nos quedó esta expresión esta expresión
de aquí